foreign
comes from Michael in Florida I'm
recently faced with a dilemma for baby
step 5. I'm currently in the position
where I can either take thirty thousand
dollars and put it in a prepaid plan for
my state Florida or take that money and
invest it in a 529 plan College Prepaid
Plan has the positives of locking in the
future cost of college tuition at
today's rate but has the downsides that
if my daughter chooses to go out of
state that the prepay plan will only
cover the equivalent cost of in-state
tuition while the 529 plan I will I will
have to consider what the cost of
tuition plan tuition is starting in 2034
which plan fits closest with the Ramsay
plan we tell people never do Prepaid
College
never
you've identified one of the reasons
your daughter might choose to go out of
state she also might choose to go to
trade school she also might choose a lot
of different things the other reason
anytime you prepay anything
like for instance a funeral
or tuition or anything
over a long period of time
your rate of return on your money
your interest rate if you will is the
inflation rate of that item so if you
prepaid bread
you know what you would make you put a
thousand dollars in bread you prepaid
your bread bill before you know and you
get free bread the rest because you
bought it ahead of time for five years
okay you know however much bread goes up
if it goes up four percent a year then
you're making four percent on your money
if it goes up 18 a year you're making
eighteen percent of your money College
tuition has for the last 75 years
averaged 7.2 percent
so that's what you would average on your
money and mutual funds have averaged 11
and a half to 12 percent the stock
market has so a you're not making as
much as you would on good mutual funds
at a regular 529 like we tell you to buy
um B she could go out of state and
here's one we could add to this this is
the whole higher ed discussion right now
how many of you think
out there in America today raise your
hands we want to see them how many of
you think that with the Epic student
loan crisis that we have
and then uh the fact that colleges
attempted to charge the same tuition to
put people through online classes during
covid
and uh
now even when they're going back to
school they're having a less than
Stellar experience in many cases
um
the campuses are out of control in a lot
of cases
how many of you think that College
is um it's kind of under attack
like I think higher Ed's you know this
idea that they they went for about 50
years they could charge whatever they
wanted to charge but now everybody
suddenly thinks they suck
um that was exactly my thought is I'm
not sure that college is going to look
the same in 15 years and I don't think
it should no I don't think it should the
system even if it does I don't think
it's going to cost as much right that's
exactly what I mean I don't think it's
going to go up seven percent faster than
anything else has gone up like it has
been I think those days are done because
people are
tired of being screwed price-wise by
higher ed and
um so I think there's going to be some
Marketplace pressure on their ability to
increase tuition hand over fist
which means your prepayment
might only make four percent rather than
seven percent I think kovid woke
everyone up now everybody's going hey
wait a minute why are we just blindly
accepting these prices and doing
whatever it takes to pay it like that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense now
that being said I definitely think you
know obviously we all believe saving for
college is important but the Prepaid
Plan specifically really lock you in
versus a traditional 529 there's a lot
more flexibility there if if higher ed
is not able to continue their price or
increases your return on investment here
is going to be nominal and that's my
that's a that's a new thing that I've
never said before because I always felt
like tuition was just going to keep
going up and I was right it kept going
up but we've had they've had a little
bit of a perfect storm hit them between
people waking up with borrowed future
and you know the documentary that's
number one documentary last year
um and we're teaching people that
stirring up a Ruckus In America that
that you know all degrees are not good
degrees a degree in left-handed puppetry
for 250 000 is stupid
and everybody's starting to say that out
loud now because you end up you know
working
I don't know 250 000 in student loan
debt and working as a barista because
you can't get a job because you're the
thing you studied nobody gives a crap
about you got a degree in you know uh
German polka history or something and
then you wonder why America doesn't owe
you a living when people are also waking
up to the fact that you don't have to go
to a 50 or 75 000 school to be
successful in life like that is not a
Golden Ticket like it's not a guarantee
just because you know you went to XYZ
fancy school that you're automatically
going to get the big expensive job like
this is not guaranteed starting to
realize that um you know I I went to the
doctor this morning I have no idea where
that lady graduated from college
she may have started her first two years
at Community College I do not know where
she got her MD
but I left there you know much better
off medically you know that's why I went
so there you go I do not know where my
dentist went to school I have no idea I
have all my teeth
but I don't know where he went to school
so well here's the thing I don't want to
knock
fancy private schools you know I do I
mean I went to Vanderbilt I love Vander
you went to Vanderbilt for free right
okay and that's my point is get the best
education you can afford if you can get
a full ride to Vanderbilt if you can get
a full ride to an Ivy League school
great but if you can't afford that
there's no shame there and you can get a
great education and a great job going to
community college first then
transferring to a public university like
where you go to school is not what's
going to make you successful you are
what makes you successful ding ding
there's a secret sauce right there
preach it sister I like it that's how it
works I love that the education system
is getting challenged I hope we're
having a totally different conversation
10 years from now about all the change
that's happened well I mean anytime you
have blind acceptance of something then
you get blind people that accept it I
mean it's just that's just oh God
so yeah it's uh and the stupids but
stuff you people are allowing to go on
on these campuses in the name of
whatever
good Lord who wants to send your child
into the Cesspool like that but Dave a
college needs a rock wall and a lazy
river
yeah
yeah under 20 000 extra dollars a year
so answer to your question Michelle or
Michael
um is
um
529 where you pick the mutual funds and
they don't move unless you move them
and you do that with your smart investor
Pro you do not do Prepaid College
because you're locked into one certain
State you do not do Prepaid College
because you are locked into college your
daughter might want to be a computer
coder and uh you don't need four years
of college to do that you need coach
school to do that it's a different thing
so that that's you know and we do not
know what's going to happen to hire it I
do not think it's I do not think
education is bad but I do not think all
education has a Marketplace value either
as a matter of fact I'm positive German
polka history does not have a
Marketplace value the only job there is
for German polka history is teaching
other people German polka history that's
the only job there is and so it's a
pretty narrow nuanced thing not even
sure it's an actual degree but it's kind
of fun to make fun of it so anyway but
yeah so that's the point so you know if
you're but it is is a four-year Business
Degree a good idea if you're going to be
in business you bet you're going to
learn I got a lot of good stuff
so all education is not bad we're not
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
but I'm just telling you this Baby's in
trouble it's been misbehaving and so uh
I would not do Prepaid College ever but
for sure in this environment I wouldn't
do it